[Music]
one way to ward off mosquitoes is to
light a coil that releases mosquito
repelling Beiber's these coils
manufactured in Thailand contain three
natural ingredients traditionally used
in this country to keep those biting
bugs at bay
eucalyptus citronella and turmeric the
first step is to mix them with certain
non active natural ingredients which
form the coil coconut shell powder
sawdust tapioca starch and Jos powder
and adhesive made from the bark and
leaves of the Litzy a glutinous 'try
then they add the coils only chemical
active ingredient meadow flu Tharin its
vapours are toxic to mosquitoes nervous
systems yet harmless to humans and low
doses a conveyor belt transports it to
an extruder which squeezes the paste
through a slot shaped dye producing
sheets approximately four millimeters
thick
a stamping machine then punches out
seven coils per sheet the leftover pace
travels back to the extruder to be
reformed into fresh sheets
after five and a half hours the coils
come out of the drying chamber hard and
sturdy after conducting another visual
inspection workers transfer the dried
coils to the automated packing line the
machines first station stacks the coils
and piles of five workers place a metal
coil stand on each stack then the
machines next station packages each
stack in clear plastic film the package
holds the five coils tightly together so
they don't rattle against each other and
get damaged it also prevents the scent
from dissipating before use at the next
station a high-speed robotic arm grabs
and opens the retail boxes aligning them
opposite the arriving packages of coils
the Machine inserts a package of coils
into each box then closes the box
provided they're kept sealed in their
plastic package and stored away from
moisture the active ingredients remain
effective for at least 10 years